to continue with the idea of social
responsibility a sense of social
responsibility as motivating
philanthropy earlier we had the
opportunity to speak with a founder of
the extra town foundation which funds a
high school in a village and guatemalan
so what might you say to a donor who is
interested in education but is like
trying to make that decision between
Yale and that other organization and
what do you think it's fair to sort of
can't try to categorize the morality of
one over another or like to say that one
donation could be as a potential or
should be considered more philanthropic
def definite no to the latter statement
philanthropist philanthropy whether it's
big or small whether it's here or there
so I would you know there's there's no
question about that but you is a very
interesting example because i have
another example to that and that is when
we launched the campaign in 2006 the
public face I you know we organized a
multimedia show to show a little bit
what the campaign was about and we
featured some of the students at the
time so it was all before your time and
I had we had two young women there who
founded mercado global you've heard of
it and you know they found it while they
were students here and they got the
training and teaching to do that here
and last I heard it's still thriving
they are not together one you know one
was in from India and she went back to
her home and the other of young woman
involved is still at it and what she is
doing is exactly what you are describing
they help women in cooperatives there
too with their crafts develop sales
channels for it help was it designed a
little bit so that it can be sold you
had people want to buy it here and all
and that the proceeds all go to pay the
women obviously for the things but the
profits all go into the school system
there so that every kid
in that cooperative can go to school now
these are two of the same things right
and but funded through to a different
way so you could say you know I can
accomplish the same goal by investing in
a person through a scholarship or that I
enable this person to come to an
institution where they can you know
develop these skills and develop this
leadership and you know they both said
they learned a lot from their master who
helped them and you know at first said
what makes you think you can do that
that was his first thing and that's
going on and they got into it so you
know you can accomplish the same things
in different ways and I think it's
entirely your decision you know where
you want to do it so would you say that
making donors aware of those like
individual investments that Yale is
responsible for making is one of your
more effective tools for kind of
encouraging donor participation the most
effective tool is to find out what
people are passionate about what they
really care about and then match it with
a need at the University you can't turn
somebody who is interested in helping
young children you can't compel this
person to give a you know and jeans
order or something like that it just
doesn't work so you have to be sensitive
and have to find out what is it that
this person wants to accomplish you know
what is history moratorium and then show
them that they can accomplish this dream
at Yale so you almost have a
philanthropic approach to philanthropy
then absolutely